le geste n'est pas encore parfait la
technique hésitante mais l'objectif
n'était pas là pour la cinquième édition
du golfe festival l'événement se voulait
ludique faire découvrir la pratique d'un
sport sujet aux préjugés alors que dans
deux ans se profile la ryder cup à saint
quentin la plus grande compétition de
golf au monde dans deux ans on accueille
le troisième événement sportif le plus
médiatisé au monde il ya plus de 600
millions de téléspectateurs et donc ça
va faire venir énormément de gens il ya
80 mille personnes par jour qui vont
venir sur le golf national
donc c'est juste pour que les gens aient
des notions de ce sport qu'ils puissent
du coup en profite et bien comprendre
tout l'intérêt tout l'intérêt de cet
évènement qu'est la ryder cup
pour sa cinquième édition le goal
festival a réuni près de 400 personnes
découverte du site ou encore pratique
pour les débutants petits ou grands
étaient ravis de cette première sur le
green
donc la première fois on touche pas du
tout la balle est beaucoup plus amusant
silva c'est vrai que c'est vraiment une
technique
et on n'est pas forcément habitué c'est
vraiment sympa c'est c'est agréable ça
détend je précise parce que c'est
marrant tout à fait savoir mme tapé dans
la balle
après j'en attends je n'avais jamais
fait chier mais pas trop ce que ça
donnait en tout cas c'est vraiment les
choses que j'ai aimé c'était bien en
france près de 800000 personnes
pratiquent régulièrement le golf un
chiffre qui devrait augmenter d'ici 2018
et la prochaine édition de la ryder cup